members of a celebrated all-girl
robotics team have made it safely out of
afghanistan we're happy to tell you that
this morning they're in qatar this
morning officials there sent a plane for
these young girls who were known as the
afghan dreamers the digital citizen fund
the team's parent organization worked
with qatar's government to get the girls
out and speed up that visa process the
team from afghanistan captured a lot of
hearts in 2017
after the us initially denied them the
visas to travel here for a competition
eventually they made it they competed
and they showed the world just how
talented and creative that they are now
that i've seen this video i remember now
yes right let's have the same reaction
it was yeah before
remember this story and then you see
them then i do remember that yeah it's
an incredible organization an incredible
group of girls and that's part of the
legacy of america's involvement there in
afghanistan that couldn't happen under
the taliban and the prior regime exactly
unfortunately they actually got out
earlier this week but it could not be
reported until today